alright go the chess shop the techno
chess the chest I refuse to call it chop
chop so there's this place in Seattle
and I'm sure most of you know by now but
just because I have to a bunch of
lefties took over a six square block
radius in Seattle they called the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone it's now
the Capitol Hill occupied protest though
they dispute what the chop really means
and one of the reasons people think
they're calling it that is because as
they said do you know what happened to
people in the French Revolution who
didn't get on board with revolution they
got chopped they did get chopped Adam is
now spinning the spinning territory
right that's trying to do it all sneaky
while you're talking we got we got 5,000
likes and then 6,000 likes like that I
was like I have to I have to spin the
UFO takes priority so take a look at
this with you everybody
it says Raz is handing out ar-15s from
the back of his Tesla did he's living it
if you have a Tesla you you're living
comfortable yeah we're privileged
isn't this the case with with a lot of
these like occupy yeah patient style
protests fun babies no look it's always
the people of means who have the ability
to actually do this that's true so take
a look at this it says in Washington to
own an assault rifle a person must be 21
plus if outside their own home or
business they can charge Raz with a
gross misdemeanor for the first transfer
to anyone under 21 then a felony for
everyone after in this video you
actually see this dude Raz now they've
been calling the warlord of the Chas
marketing now holy cow he walked into
his car he's armed and let me let me try
and shout bad he pops open his trunk he
says something like you know who does
who knows how to use a weapon or
whatever okay let me this bigger there
we go
this guy right here in the sweater he
walks up he's the rightful owner
someone took my GoPro how old do you
think this dude is right here 20 maybe
yeah maybe torn I don't know you he
looks like it could be 18 seriously so
here's here's the first
question but maybe it maybe it's too
early 20s I don't know though here's a
question that maybe they buy the clip
maybe here's a question that maybe the
chat will know can you legally just hand
a rifle to someone in Washington to just
use however they want now you can see
the dude walking around with these with
these rifles so I'll tell you what man
is the only argument that he gave a
rifle to someone under the age of 18 or
under the age of 8 H of 21 in my opinion
we don't have find really funny where
all the gun control lefties to be alike
you shouldn't be able to lend a gun to
somebody I don't think you can I don't
think that's legal I think you can in
some in some places that's why I throw
it to the jeno can you argue are you
allowed to take a weapon and be like oh
you go there saying no you can't do over
well I don't know if you've actually
asked yet or maybe you did but it's
steer it's an overwhelming no anyway I
feel bad this res is gonna get that guy
killed yeah yep that whoever it is looks
like a kid but if he's over 18 he's a
man he's an adult as far as we're
concerned in this country so he was
given a gun he clearly has no idea he
was holding it like this holding the
clip of the gun and he's a nice well
that is imagine oh yeah but okay res
called it a clip I see people being like
it's a magazine not a clip to magazine
yeah I guess that's a different
different kind of guns different so he
says
titles take the slip up then put it back
in and the kids like clueless know what
he's doing I say kid figuratively don't
know how old he is
so look man I got to say I take I'm kind
of concerned about some random in young
person who clearly has no idea to handle
this weapon yeah just being clearly not
handed it man here is your wreck he's
gonna get him killed
yeah so so here's what Crowder said
steven crowder of louder with Crowder oh
tweet it in my lifetime I've never
feared witnessing an actual civil war
but when an American city is taken over
by lawless criminals with guns can
anyone be surprised when citizens try to
take it back also with guns turn back
now please
Chazz chop first I know exactly what the
lefty media's gonna do here they're
gonna do what steven crowder without
evidence claimed that far left us with
guns took over an American city
as we all know a six-block portion of
Seattle has been occupied the way crowdy
described it that's their that's that's
the media takedown tactic oh he says an
American cities been taken over false
nothing to worry about everybody carry
on cuz the New York Times and all these
other media outlets are praising what
they're doing saying everything's fine I
love it
CNN CNN and one day Oliver Darcy writes
armed antiva aren't taking over this
space that says if you listen to the
right here's what they'll tell you on
that same day an on-the-ground reporter
talking I believe it was the same day
talking Anderson Cooper said now
Anderson you got to realize these people
are armed and there is a potential for
bloodshed should law enforcement try to
take it back so what was there's a
leader of an Tifa like in there talking
about look I don't even I don't even
agree with everything they're doing here
but I forget he was all he's got all
sorts of piercings I don't know his name
I forget there's a bunch of name no you
know mitts that he's he's without an
Tifa and he's like I'm not with them but
I'm here because this is where the
actions at and I'm gonna stay here and
do what I need to do now I don't agree
with them but I don't care here's what
they like to do CNN says ant EFA's not
even a real group it's an idea it just
means anti-fascist then as soon as you
get that idea
walking around guns and they call
themselves like John Brown gun club or
something they go well no anti fajir
because they're you know no one from the
organization is here it's like wait what
you were the one who said it was an idea
so now that we're saying yes the people
there of these various groups like Rose
City an tyfa and Puget Sound John Brown
Gun Club those are an tyfa affiliated
organizations the apparatus sells
independently but they have leaders they
have weapons they clearly buy stuff
right now there's video going around
where apparently these these are john
brown gun club people aren't vehicles
with no license plates yes uh so yes
they're there they're active mm-hmm now
look man I don't think I man I wanna I
want to keep leaning on the side of this
is probably gonna be silly and kind of
just wash away one day I don't know
though man
I don't know eventually they're starting
to deep like deconstruct man they're
they're beaten up some some kid who I
guess stole money out of a and some keys
out of a
Carla they beat him up they took him and
Raz was standing there like trying to
let tell tell them to let go of him and
the dude who had him was like you shut
up yeah and I was like whoa he told Raz
to shut up and then started to beat the
daylights out of this guy they already
assaulted someone it's like they don't
have Law & Order it's it's what I was
saying was a lawless place they have a
warlord and the Warlord's not even in
control the guy he was to usir as clear
as day telling the other guy to stop
we're gonna try to figure this out and
the dude was like nah I'm from the hood
I'm not some celebrity I forget what he
said it's um what was he
what does Raz knows before he's
soundcloud rapper he's like I'm not a
soundcloud rapper I'm from the hood yeah
and then he knocks his dude out man
pummels him is that no no no stop you
can't stop me you shut your mouth oh he
said I'm not like you or sound clever
I'm gonna do this I watched a video or
they surround a guy and they accuse him
of being a thief and they're like why'd
you run why'd you run if you didn't do
anything
it's like bro let me let me tell you if
a mob of lawless people with guns and
baseball bats and pitchforks are
screaming burn the witch yeah I'm
running yeah I'm not gonna sit there and
be like hey I turned myself into you
guys who clearly have no cohesive
thought in your brains or you are just a
mindless mob Chang burn the witch
yeah I'm running yeah that's a sign of
guilt to them man it's it's it's like I
was gonna make an analogy but I know
it's gonna offend some people do it
Libya do it maybe after the fall of
Moses face Gaddafi yeah all the rival
gangs are fighting and it was just cast
in the streets I know
Libya was much much much worse than a
bunch of dumb hippies dancing in the
street that's why I'm just making a
light analogy that you've got roving
factions trying to assert their random
authority over a random place it doesn't
work
yeah Chaz is not just a hippie zone
definitely not you know what man on the
surface maybe when I when I saw Occupy
Wall Street and I saw this I'm like I
know it occupy was like I really think
this will just get washed out eventually
but the fact that you've got people like
Raz handing
out you know rifles to people they're
not playing games I mean they let me
rephrase that they're literally playing
games because they're morons and they
don't realize how bad it will really get
ya until that kid gets killed but
they're playing for keeps
okay that kid's gonna get killed man I
think so I mean well look by now he's
probably given the gun back
I hope so could you imagine what would
happen if like people started shooting
that kid would have no idea what he was
doing
none and he'd be a target cuz he'd have
a gun he PI D permit he might shoot
himself or some innocent people someone
right next to him without knowing yeah
so you've got you know the point at
Crowder is making what's to stop some
armed I don't say right-wing necessarily
yeah but you know there was a preacher
who showed up and he had a magnet had a
megaphone in a speaker PA yeah and he
was trying to preach so a bunch of
people grabbed him pinned him down held
him and stole his stuff you know the
same same dude who was they were set is
the anti fleet one of the antifa leaders
from Portland he was saying I I run in
Tifa in Portland was one of the people
that was choking that day yeah I saw his
picture and and II Noah's report on who
that guy is yeah this guy so what you
need to understand about an tyfa is that
it's an it's an umbrella it's it's a
it's a cell organization type group an
tyfa dates back to communist - jerk -
what Devine mar Germany I believe I'm
prancing right where the Communist Party
had a paramilitary wing antifascist
action they flew that flag auntie Fudd
today uses propaganda to say it just
means you oppose fascism right they're
actually revolutionary communists one of
the one of the highest profile antiph Oh
websites is run by a group called Rev
calm revolutionary communism and they
literally wear uniforms and they have
boots and they goose-step at protests we
see him all the time so this dude who's
down there the guy you're talking about
who's pinning down this preacher
is part of I believe Rose City an tyfa a
branded cell boom so I see I see this
propaganda pop pop popping up all over
the place there's no such thing exempt
Aoife like I don't know they're there
they're openly saying that they're there
right but this is well-to-do liberals
who don't actually read the news they
just get their information off of CNN
and then they see memes and so like
right these really long thought-out post
explaining
very neutrally what an Tifa is without
criticizing I'm just like here's how the
operations they do and then people are
like oh and I explained to them very
simply yeah the reason Donald Trump
wants to designate an Tifa terrorists
doesn't mean literally they're going to
take us the word an tyfa and place it on
top of a board that says terrorists it's
so that if somebody throws a brick
through a window
they say vandalism if somebody is
wearing the anti foot patch and throws a
brick through a window they say
terrorism because you are using violence
to push a political ideology definition
of terrorism yes I'm not saying I'm a
big fan of the Patriot Act stuff I'm not
at all I'm just trying to explain to you
what Trump was trying to do with that so
here's what I think might happen you get
the John Brown Gun Club affiliated not
like this getting this guy was in Willem
van Willem vanspronsen vanspronsen yeah
shows up to a nice facility I think last
year or the year before last year last
year with a ghost
they are so home-built rifle ok fire
bombs and starts just bombing the the
the ice facility torches one of the
vehicles wasn't able to get the building
I believe he was shooting at the police
they shot and killed him wow that was
Puget Sound John Brown Gun Club yeah the
same people who are walking around the
chop the Chaz with rifles Wow
so in the u.s. you they can't do
anything about that their affiliation
because of the First Amendment you have
a right to express your opinions
whenever but the point is if these Peter
town guys do something terroristic I
wouldn't be surprised if they get
charged under terrorism statutes yeah or
these Rose City guys but I'll tell you
what man it's funny it's it's it's not a
game to these people that a preacher on
an American Street gets thrown to the
ground and pinned down by multiple
people as they steal his stuff that time
you can't be here I don't know if he was
an official preacher no no I'm saying I
was preaching it for sure right right so
so I don't mean to say that he's like
literally flew with the church no no in
America you're allowed to stand where
you want and speak right so think about
it this way well at the time they were
still Chazz which would be their own
country they were claiming now they've
changed it to chop because they were
colonizers and they were concerned like
we conquered this land because they had
an army marching at them they're like
no no we're still this is Steinem Eric I
don't know that's the real reason that
I'm saying it but here's here's a poem
trying to make about this because it
should be you've got this preacher he's
got his PA system and he wants to preach
you know he said he said I wanna you
know speaking about speaking on a king
or whatever he's clearly going there to
defy them definitely now what happens
when the next that then we saw some
people walk through with American flags
I mean and for the record those that
same kind of person goes out to the
streets to defy everyone because they
think everyone's a sinner you know I've
seen him in New York yeah you see him in
New York yours they stand there and they
preach to everyone have you ever seen
that video where the guy tries to punch
the preacher and he catches his fist yes
money the smile that comes out is yes
I'm not a fan of these guys you know why
my I've actually tried talking to them
and they don't they tell me nothing
because the preachers you mean yeah not
all of them obviously it's like but
whatever
let them exactly talk I know I'm not
gonna listen I don't have hears you I'm
not super concerned about a preacher
showing up I am concerned about anti-fog
literal known branded cell anti-fur
actor who's been arrested before with
his mugshot being released pinning a guy
down with the help of others to steal
his stuff because they don't like what
he's saying and then and then do you see
the video of him being completely
unconscious dragged down the block the
preacher guy same creature oh I don't
know completely passed out completely he
was out cold
they were just dragging him down the
street wow man I mean you don't you
don't see what happened beforehand but I
mean you put it all together well so
pretty sure they messed him up a couple
people wearing American flag bandanas
carrying American flags walked through
yeah and then somewhere happens stole it
from him yeah clearly going there to
defy the far-left protesters yeah how
long until the same thing happens but
this time they've got four guys on each
you know sending in a formation with
ar-15s I'm I'm surprised we haven't seen
it and then at what point you know what
they've got their you know they'll have
a confederate patch or an American flag
patch or three percenters or oathkeepers
and then one of these John Brown Gun
Club guys or this dumb kid who sees them
and panics and says what do I do
and so he's holding hold weapony any
points and then the actual trained legit
guys are like drop
drop it and they put him down and they
will or the curb fires or the kid sees
them and panics and starts in all art oh
man that that's what I see happening
because he clearly had no idea what he
was doing he was like oh yeah I want to
play this video game this video games
dope look he's got a Tesla new Tesla
with guns in the back yeah let me get
one too seriously cool what I think what
do I do with this what do I do you claim
to keep so what do I do with my hands
that's a real gun dude yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you